sex robots are coming that's upon people
yeah we've talked a bunch about sex pots
before I'm a firm believer that in the
next 10 years or so people are gonna
start having sex with robot they're
probably doing it right now a French
artist drew something that I think is an
interesting depiction of what he thinks
at least sex spots are gonna look like
so this is actually CGI and basically
he's showing you that you know this
thing cut in half hopefully it'll have
two abs when you're having sex with it
but just showing that there's gonna be a
lot of parties and we're really that
this is what the future there's gonna be
look at that little brain right there
this computer in the brain you've got
the entry hole which has an arrow that's
nice just in case you don't know where
the vagina is above that appears to be a
target the target does seem unnecessary
there's some barcodes it looks like on
the bottom right there the robot has
artificial reproductive organs and now
if this isn't enough for you we've got a
video of a robot stripper
let's take
[Music]
[Music]
all right so a couple things there she
seems to be bruised behind her legs
which seems weird why she wearing a mask
she's a robot
robots shouldn't have shame anyway I
just think this topic is interesting and
fun because it combines sex in the
future which i think is fun robot sex
will you have it when it comes I mean if
I need to have it I guess I will I mean
you have urges you have needs and
thankfully for now I'm okay right but I
I don't have any problem with robot sex
there are people out there who you know
need sexual gratification in one way or
another and maybe this will help them
out so I'm all for it whatever
advancements in technology awesome there
you go so we just did the porn story I
mean it's sort of the just next
extension of that right like you know
it's there it's on your computer right
there and then next thing you know
you're banging a robot I've been with a
lot of women so I've had plenty of
robots next huh okay all right I don't
know if that was quite that should have
been low fat or the I can we go back to
the CGI thing real quick yes let's go
back to the original image a lot of us
like that you're like why doesn't
everyone have anal sex sometimes like I
mean they're both right there they're
just like I mean it's like there's no
like what's the you seem like daddy or
like why is it even taboo it makes you
wonder right also why is this robot have
so much machinery behind it it could
have been in a bed you know it means but
he drew it to have a lot of other wires
you know that that 78% of have stuff in
the middle is all [ __ ] that's just
to drive the price up you know there's
like two things that make it work that
make it do this which is pretty much the
only thing that woman yeah
that's all that's all she needs well
that woman is not directly related to
that robot that's just as far come with
it with the dancing sex robot do you
think men or women are gonna do this
more because I think it's a question
it's a question because I think by
default right yeah I think by default
everyone's gonna think men right you're
gonna think man but I also think there's
women I know many women they all are
very frustrated with men not all of them
but like oh there's a lot of single
women
not because the men don't want to [ __ ]
them they're usually frustrated for
others or for others but I feel like
there's a lot of women that just have
like sort of had it with men at least
maybe that's what I see around here I
think is a ridiculous one but then we're
gonna be [ __ ] the robot but you're
but your overall point is probably true
like here it is it will be
overwhelmingly men right but we would be
surprised at the number of women sure
some women will take advantage of it I
mean women love their vibrators so why
wouldn't they like this sex toy
it's definitely plausible but I think
you know men are probably gonna want to
have sex with a machine at higher rates
what I'm actually more interested in is
how many dudes look at that CGI image
and think like oh yeah right cuz it's
kind of right and I guess some of them
do like well that'll probably become a
fetish in and of itself like I bang
robots I would be remiss if I didn't end
this segment asking one of my favorite
questions on the show which is what year
do you think the robots will take over
I'm not talking about the sex BOTS but
I'm a firm believer the machines are
coming they're on their way
what year do you think I'm gonna go with
I don't know 2050 didn't steai that's I
don't have any idea what I'm talking
about but Stephen Hawking just had his
voice box replaced you're not his voice
box but the thing that James format it's
much better and he was amazed at the
growth and artificial intelligence and
he essentially said hey look it's done
it's coming basically taking over
society not as in like Oh robots are
gonna kill us but they take over your
jobs they take over certain elements of
society that we need humans for right
now and that could actually lead to the
destruction of a lot of different things
yeah but you know what the one thing
that robots can't replace is the talking
human mind that we've given you here
today that's not necessarily true okay I
would totally watch a robot talk show we
got like two or three of them on The
Young Turks
[Applause]
[Music]